[Musik]
und mit diesem wundervollen intro meine
damen und herren darf ich sehr sehr
herzlich begrüßen hier zu einem erneuten
video von lukas beauty palace ich habe
hier unter der kamera bereits
verschiedene jule ist auch mit dabei
unter der kamera hier sind verschiedene
make up utensilien vorbereitet wie
beispielsweise einen stamm spongebob
oder pinsel oder noch mehr pinsel oder
dann haben wir beispielsweise noch ein
pinsel und wir haben auch tatsächlich
noch ein pinsel und dann haben wir hier
noch um nasenhaare raussuchen
wir haben auf jeden fall eine menge
menge make-up krams rumliegen und das
ist alles zur verfügung gestellt worden
von julia ist nämlich gerade hier
ungeschminkt und ihr sitzt bereits ein
eingeschränktes bereits mittel
eingeblendet ich bin keine freundin und
es war schwierig heute jule die ist so
ungeschminkt noch von daher würde ich
sagen ich hab ja so ein bisschen
erfahrung das ist ein bisschen ich war
in new york 30 jahre meines lebens make
up artist deswegen würde ich sagen zu
aller erst schafften wir eine gewisse
grundlage auf deinem gesicht die ist
nämlich noch nicht vorhanden hier vorne
haben wir nämlich mayday make up when i
vor alsmann ist damit 24 stunden made to
stay
das ist ein ganz ganz tolles produkt das
könnt ihr kaufen
[Musik]
ersten sechs kommen neues merchandiser
also ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt
mit diesem wunderschönen produkt hier an
der schule setze mir ein bisschen
aufrecht dahin genau damit weiter lösen
weil sonst wenn wir so toll oder du bist
du weiß wie mein t shirt alter das
allererste was wir so ein produkt macht
ist natürlich das aufmachen dann packen
wir das auf diesen schwammen darauf
würde ich jetzt einfach mal sagen weil
ich das bei dir schon sein oder andere
mal gesehen habe ich war es auf jeden
fall auf den schwamm braucht meine damen
und herren spreche da wirklich mit
reichlicher erfahrung von meiner new
york seit also wenn jetzt hier so eine
kleine mandl größe auf dem schwamm bau
und die sind wäre ich jetzt auf jedes
stehen erst mal bewegen das heißt wir
sind fertig fühlst du dich wohl also wir
verteilen dass wir schön auf der stirn
bei jule ich gebe mir wirklich wirklich
wirklich mühe
es gibt auch videos wo ich mir beim
schminken nicht so viel möglich im radio
gibt bin ich beim make up artisten und
ich glaube wenn ich so ein laden hätte
dann würde ich die ganze zeit auch
mitsingen dann haben die einerseits mich
quasi die erfahrung ich die schminke und
andererseits gucke ich jetzt mal an mal
auf meine freundlichkeit dann halt
andererseits will ich dann auch noch
singen da haben wir noch ein
privatkonzert von mir also das wäre
natürlich echt eigentlich super
erfahrung schreibt mir die kommentare
auch in den salon besuchen würde ja das
mit den lippen das war aus versehen aber
hier vorne machen wir noch ein bisschen
weiter vorne um dann machen wir hier
unten noch so ein bisschen was ich hier
machen wir noch was mehrere oder seite
meine nase zünden
die andere nein und ich würde sagen weil
davon hätte grundlage haben wir
geschaffen was man jetzt als nächstes
machen würde wäre glaube ich an der
stelle dann die lippen oder für die
lippen habe ich natürlich etwas ganz
besonderes vorbereitet und zwar einen
lavera naturkosmetik haben den kann man
es einfach mal aufklappen können wir
sehen wir schon die können wir auch
sogar auf so hoch oder auch ganz neues
produkt auf dem markt kann man gerade
kaufen
havelstadt.de nun benutzen wir das
einfach er mich gibt es ein bisschen
mehr an die damit ihr mal sehen wie
genau ich das mache und zwar nehme den
einfach mit mach mal so ich kann das
nicht so jetzt gehen wir dann nein so
virtuos und nun da unten genau jetzt
bist du dumm ja ein paar sekunden später
[Gelächter]
ich hasse es mit amateuren
das wichtige ist dass wir hierbei jetzt
den fehler von beginn übermalen weil ich
das mit dem abgerutschten auf der lippe
das übermalen dass sie einfach so ein
bisschen so wenn man die krippen haben
möchte ganz easy einfach gesagt ein
bisschen weiter darüber mal da haben wir
eigentlich als nächstes würde ich sagen
wir eine von diesen verschiedenen inseln
die wir hier wirklich vorbereitet haben
die ich hier vorbereitet die ich hier
vorbereitet habe und würde ich an der
stelle nicht empfehlen wir nehmen hier
verschiedene wir haben verschiedene
arten
wir haben hier sogar einen doppel pinsel
der ist nämlich ganz besonders toll wenn
man dafür dass beim schminken
gleichzeitig die nicht da warum nicht
dass meine show lukas beauty pelle das
nächste was wir hier nämlich verwenden
ist der grímsson brands inc
das ist eine mega mega tolles produkt
meine damen und das kann ich wirklich
jedem mädchen und auch jedem jungen der
schmink begeistert ist einfach nur ans
herz legen am das ist bruder
da ist
das ganze hier so ein bisschen mehreren
vertreiben um dann halt besonders hier
so einen gewissen teil zur halbzeit als
es warum du darfst das rennen
wichtig ist bei meiner kundschaft auch
das nicht geschaut wird in den spiegel
beziehungsweise in dem fall in die
kamera ich kann natürlich auch schminken
ohne spiegel das ist mir ganz besonders
wichtig weil das ist sowieso wir oben
sage ich mal wir oben rum war früher
richtig scheiße und dann haben sie
wirklich richtig langsam gebaut dann
richtig viele baustellen das richtige
aus und jetzt ist eine schönste schöne
stadt
du bist dann gesicht ist eine baustelle
und mal behalten die schöne stadt auf
ein für papa als nächstes haben wir dann
hier etwas das ist für die augenbrauen
da ist es für die augen drin ich habe
ein bisschen angst vor dass du mit ihren
auswahlen will man machen wir augen
wurden nicht nach wien fahren mache ich
mir da wird da werde ich bin man das nie
bei mir ist es aber nicht alle an
wie gehts bei mir ist es halt so dass
ich so viel arbeit und so viel liebe
schon in das komplette gesicht stecke
dass man die wimpern gar nicht machen
muss dass ich geld nicht brauche was ist
das
ich brauche die wimpern nicht machen es
ist es eben die wimperntusche
da kann man die ganz einfach rausziehen
dass sie mir schon da da da haben wir
sie und da müssen wir jetzt so ein
bisschen die wimpern hier genau kürze
freund da als nächstes würde ich dann
einfach das hier empfehlen das sieht auf
den ersten blick aus wie bleistifte
anspitzer ist es allerdings nicht sein
dass in anspruch das ist ein spitzenjahr
hast du dann spitzenschwinger für so ein
stift oder so wenn du den notizen was
durch das nächste was denkst du das ist
wie dein video hier haben wir ein
produkt meine damen und herren ihr seht
schon hier vorne eingeblendet ich pack
mal kurz meine hand davor
damit man das ganze mein fokus jedoch
jetzt so sieht dieses produkts hieraus
ihr seht schon dass sich super klasse
aus und das kann
einfach verwenden um die namen doch das
ist für die nasen einkommen macht jetzt
augenbrauen augen zu ich mache mir die
augenbrauen hiermit und sachsen die
erste nase raus jetzt kommen jetzt was
ich das doch auch das ist ein stift ja
war ich die ganze zeit
dieser stift ist eigentlich für notizen
da das ist aber auch eine super funktion
wir haben einerseits was für die
nasenhaare und da kannst du nebenbei
noch notiz machen während wir den nasa
herausschießt die jule meint sie würde
die augenbrauen benutzen ich weiß nicht
warum der anderen seite noch ein
bisschen weiter
man möchte ja zeigen dass dann wirklich
einen gehörigen augenbrauen geht's mit
zur anderen seite genau augenbrauen dass
man ungeordnete ordentliches wachstum
hat dann gehen wir hier den stift können
wir damit jetzt allerdings auch wieder
zuklappen und an die seite parken du dir
was du zuerst ist es machen wir können
einfach mal schauen wie sie allein die
dame das möchte ich meine ich dachte
natürlich auch auf die wünsche seiner
kunden dass sie gerade gefragt ob sie es
weiß
[Gelächter]
tja da wollte ich auch ein punkt ist wie
so ein dalmatiner die braucht jetzt
überall so ein paar punkte hier im
gesicht so da da da da da da da genauso
zeigt hier über und nochmal augen zu
lassen genau genau wie ich bin sofort
ich genauso hier gar nichts mehr dafür
den eyeliner jetzt auch beendet haben
kommt als allerletztes jetzt ist als
letztes jahr meine damen und herren
kommt jetzt meine wundervolle palette
wanted von naked smokie deswegen hierbei
ist es wichtig dass man sehr behutsam
vorgeht bei der farbwahl da wir uns
jetzt frontal in die kamera wir sehen
jetzt bei julius gesicht einen
rot-schwarzen das heißt wir nehmen hier
diese farbe grün passt dann glaube ich
super
hierbei ist es nun wichtig dass wir uns
das gesicht des kunden bzw der personen
die hier geschminkt wird ganz genau
anschauen schauen mich mal an
du scheiße deswegen würde ich sagen wir
hierfür so ein bisschen hier die nase so
leicht genau hier war und dann noch hier
machen wir doch mal einfach so einen
kreis und damit wir den punkt da oben so
ein bisschen nach einkreisen und sogar
ein bisschen mehr freuen
ich habe juden und fertig geschminkt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das heißt ihr seht jetzt eine aufnahme
wie jule nun aussieht
[Musik]
an der stelle wo ich das heute wieder
nicht beenden meine damen und herren
juli kommen noch mal mit ins bild jetzt
ihr gefallen
super ich fand's toll sollen die leute
entlassen
schreibt man die kommentare freunde
sollen lukas beauty care ist demnächst
eventuell noch mal etwas mit make up
machen sollte eventuell nochmal eine
glossybox bestellen und einfach in die
weltcup ausprobieren soll ich irgendwie
einer anderen scheiß machen den dass ich
mal ein hall mache was ich mir dann das
bin ich für ein mensch an der stelle
durch das video jetzt aber auch beenden